es ist einer der erdähnlichen planeten
die bisher vom planeten sucher kepler
entdeckt wurden 77 11 wir hatten ja
schon über die neue version der
exoplaneten liste berichtet aber noch
nicht über diesen spektakulären fund
laut der wissenschaftlerin natalie
batalha ist es der erdähnlichste planet
den kepler bisher entdeckt hat mehr über
einen fund der durchaus umstritten ist
jetzt krieg zum science fiction
kepler ist ein besonderer satellit der
kreis nämlich nicht um die erde sondern
um die sonne genau wie die erde zieht er
seine bahnen um unser zentralgestirn um
nicht weil der erdumkreisung ständig
durch den erdschatten gestört zu werden
so hat kepler freie bahn und kann
ungestört nach exoplaneten suchen dafür
wurde das weltraumteleskop nämlich 2009
in den weltraum geschickt eben um
exoplaneten und vor allem erdähnliche zu
finden
inzwischen ist die liste der kandidaten
für exoplaneten ziemlich lang geworden
bei der beobachtung von 190.000 stern
ist kepler immerhin auf rund 4.000
mögliche exo planeten gestoßen und rund
50 von ihnen sind ähnlich darüber hat
mir ja berichtet allerdings ist ein
kandidat bei 77 11 etwas besonderes
steht dabei für keppler object of
interest also peppler objekt von
interesse
77 11 befindet sich nämlich in der
umlaufbahn um einen stern der unsere
sonne ziemlich ähnlich ist wurden zudem
in der habitablen also
lebensfreundlichen zone um die diesen
stern also nicht zu weit weg dann würde
zu kalt und nicht zu nah dann wäre es zu
heiß zudem ist vor 7711 nur wenig größer
als die erde und haben mit 302 tagen
auch eine ähnliche umlaufzeit um dem
stern wissenschaftlerin natalie batalha
vom kepler projekt sagt dass das mit ko
ii 7 7 11 zum ersten mal ein planet
dabei ist der mit einem rund 30 prozent
wollte umfang und einer umlaufzeit um
den stern von etwa einem jahr der erde
sehr ähnlich sei bei seiner position in
der habitablen zone ist zudem die
existenz von wasser und damit leben sehr
wahrscheinlich vor 7711 wäre damit hat
sich eine der top kandidaten für
außerirdisches leben doch es gibt
letztlich zu viele fragezeichen gibt es
wirklich wasser hat der planet ein
magnetfeld das eine atmosphäre schützen
würde eine eigene rotation und so weiter
her müsste halt noch zahlreiche
bedingungen erfüllen um wirklich ein
kandidat für leben auf einem exoplaneten
zu werden trotzdem zeigt die entdeckung
von koi 7711 das ist mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit ersten zahlreiche
planeten mit idealen bedingungen für
leben geben könnte
und das war mit zweitens die
wahrscheinlichkeit steigt erdähnliche
planeten zu finden und auch solche auf
denen leben dann
rechtlich möglich ist und drittens
könnten wir dann auch wirklich leben
finden noch gucken wer wirklich halb
blind ins weltall auch bei cat werk
nicht mehr voll funktionsfähig ist und
weil die auflösung der aktuellen
teleskopen der den neuen
weltraumteleskopen deutlich
hinterherhinkt wenn nächstes jahr das
james webb weltraumteleskop ins all
startet und 2009/10 seine arbeit
aufnimmt dann werden wir eine neue stufe
der forschung erreichen können das
riesen weltraumteleskop hat eine achtung
hundertfach bessere auflösung als habe
wir werden so viel mehr über das weltall
erfahren auch kriegs- und wird damit
eine neue stufe erreichen es wird hier
nur sensationellen news trassen aber
auch jetzt schon gibt es hier täglich
neue videos mit teilweise wirklich
unglaublichen wissenschafts news wenn
schon jetzt gibt es immer öfter
bahnbrechende erkenntnisse zum berichten
ja wenn ihr kein video davon verpassen
wollt dann wird mir hier ein abo
aufsaugen vergessen steht auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit außerirdisches
leben auf proxima centauri b ein
weiterer kandidat für außerirdisches
leben und ansonsten also drauf klicken
wenn es euch interessiert also ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran